An update now on
a disturbing story out of Kenya
that we've been following very closely.
More than
300 bodies
have been found in shallow graves
in a forest
and authorities say scores of mass graves
are yet to be uncovered.
Most of the victims
were followers
of a controversial pastor
who is now in police custody
His followers were allegedly brainwashed
into believing that starvation
was their ticket to salvation.
CNN's David McKenzie
traveled to the area.
He joins us live now from Johannesburg.
So, David,
even though the pastor,
Pastor McKenzie's, is being held
at this point in time,
the psychological wounds for.
Yes, the family members of the victims,
but also the community
at large will take a very long time
to heal.
Just walk us through
what was said by the people you spoke to.
Well, certainly
the wounds will be there for a long time.
And the true scale of this horror
hasn't even yet been fully uncovered.
Zain.
And it is sort of described
how long it will take.
65 of the followers of this cult
are still refusing to eat.
They believe that the pastor
held their ticket to salvation
and that salvation
was the way to get there.
And I must warn some viewers
that the themes
and images
in the story could be disturbing.
He called it the wilderness,
luring his flock
to a remote corner of Kenya.
We've come to try and understand
how over many months so many could die
in the shack, a hole of forest.
The dead are still being found.
Forensic teams carefully remove
the remains of members
of a Christian death cult
from shallow graves.
They have already unearthed
more than 300 people
many of them children,
many showing signs of starvation.
It's painful,
just so painful.
It was so painful.
This is my daughter.
Francis Wanja says his daughter
and son in law
both abandoned
good jobs and took their children
to the forest cult.
What happened next is hard to comprehend.
It today a tribute to Jesus
and they have to start with the children.
The members of the cult,
including your own family.
They were starving the children. Yes.
And then when the children didn't
die quickly enough to suffocate them,
suffocate them? Yes.
And this is your own blood.
And I wonder where my children
or my child my daughter
could change
to be such an animal.
A world animal
to kill her own children.
Pastor Paul McKenzie began
his cult in Malindi.
This is the church where Pastor McKenzie
had a huge following in his sermons.
Yes, he amplified his message online.
He preached a doomsday prophecy
for at least a decade,
calling on the faithful
to reject modern society,
poor children from school,
avoid hospitals.
He demanded total devotion.
Study to kill time.
You must deny yourself.
You must reject yourself.
You must reach a point
of ending your life, he says.
For the sake of Jesus,
his anti-government
stance got him arrested and detained,
but never prosecuted.
In 2019, the church was closed down.
Later,
the pastor started his forest community
We found a former cult member in Malindi.
We agreed to hide her identity
for her own safety.
She escaped the forest last year.
Why did you move your whole home
and all your children
and move into the forest?
Oh, I'm fine. Yes.
The pastor used to call me.
She says he was calling me, telling me
my daughter.
You are being left behind.
And when the ark is closed,
it will be too late. So I decided to go.
When the COVID pandemic hit,
she says, many saw it
as evidence that the prophecies
were real.
McKenzie charged her family $80
for a piece of land in Galilee.
There were seven
other biblically named settlements
in Kajola,
with more than a thousand followers,
she says.
Still, cult members
made regular trips
to a nearby village for food
and water in December.
Those trips suddenly
stopped, says this village elders
among them
to try not to stick up anymore.
The starvation had begun,
she declared, Would you name it?
He says they alerted authorities,
but they did nothing.
Even after hungry
children started escaping to the village,
what's been called the Shaka
Houla massacre has shocked this nation.
Pastor McKenzie and his closest
followers are being held
anti-terror laws.
What happened in the forest
with your followers?
I can tell nothing about that
because I've been in custody
for two months.
So I don't know
what is going outside then.
Have you been there
Francis Windsor
says there needs to be justice.
He mounted a rescue mission
to get his grandchildren out
when they found his grandson, Ephraim.
He was close to starvation.
His two brothers were already dead.
He went through hell
he went through hell.
I'm telling. In fact,
when he was rescued, he told him that
if you could come here,
maybe let a bit late.
What did you find me?
I had already gone to see Jesus.
Cause
the grave is there
now.
At the very highest levels
of the Kenyan government
have apologized for their inaction
and the pain it has caused
the scale
of what happened in the forest
is still being understood.
Hundreds are still missing,
and many more mass graves
need to be exhumed
David McKenzie is with me again now.
I mean, the fact that this could happen,
I mean, that video was so distressing,
the fact that this could happen
really does beggar belief.
David,
how much has this prompted
soul-searching
among Kenya's leaders,
especially because of that inaction?
As you point out in your piece,
It has prompted a great deal
of soul-searching, Zain.
And certainly the president,
the interior ministers
and others, as I said,
have apologized for that inaction
on the ground.
Many people were frustrated that
they had warned
the authorities that warned the police
there were strange things
happening in that forest
and it needed to be invested
adding it ended up being
Francis and private rescue mission
that seem to have unearthed this properly
for the first time.
And there is this awkward
juxtaposition here.
William Ruto,
the country's
president, is the first offense
elected president in the country.
Faith is very central to his rule.
And, of course, no one is suggesting that
that pastors will go to these lengths.
But many people I spoke to
said that they feel
there needs to be more regulation
of the religious sector in Kenya.
They say that
there are pastors
who are taking advantage of people
every day
separating them from their
well earned money,
promising things
that they can't actually deliver.
This, of course, allegedly
what happened is a far more extreme case.
And I think it should be placed
into the context of the worst
mass suicides that we have seen globally.
For many years now.
And the cult following
that this man allegedly
developed is in line with previous
instances of these kind of cults
in the global context.
But really,
there is going to be a lot
of soul-searching
and people
are calling for regulations
and to protect Kenyans from these
kind of leaders,
these kind of religious leaders that
are David McKenzie
live for us, thank you.